i got in trouble over the weekend oh was
i
in trouble because i tweeted out i said
that it is not permissible
for christians to vote for joe biden
the tweet went viral lots of ignorant
leftists
said a lot of very ignorant things about
the tweet but the biggest objection that
people had
is that i was conflating politics and
religion and you're not allowed to do
that how dare you do that our founders
are rolling over their graves that's
what they all thought
i've got news for you though all
politics is religious
the way you vote says a lot about how
you view yourself
how you view your place in the world how
you view your place
in the world to come and the
consequences could last a lot longer
than four years i'm michael nolsas the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back i hate getting in trouble i
actually i don't really mind i sort of
like it sometimes if
we can change people's minds then i am
more than willing to get in trouble and
i think we can first though
my favorite comment from thursday from
goggleman seven
actually the democrats are voting for
country over party
they're voting for china that's true
they're not voting for our country over
the party but they might be voting for
another country
over that party you know this is going
to be a crazy crazy week obviously
the biggest political night of every
four years
is happening tomorrow night and somehow
by the way
i feel rested i don't know how i mean
this is the craziest most stressful time
you know the daily wires moving to
nashville somehow i feel
rested i feel at peace is this because
there's some greater kind of political
piece in the world no it's because i
have my pillow that's why i feel good
mike lindell you know mike lindell a
very important conservative and
christian voice
he is the inventor of my pillow i
so look forward to putting my head on my
my pillow pillow every night
or initially we only got one my pillow
and so elise and i fought over it but i
took it i don't care it doesn't
chivalry is dead if it means i'm the one
that gets my my pillow
they have so many other great products
too though mike's latest deal is on his
giza dreams
sheets which are made from the world's
best cotton giza they're ultra soft and
breathable extremely durable right now
the giza dreams sheets are at a two for
one
low price plus free shipping with promo
code
daily wire you know i love mike lindell
i've been a big fan of his for a long
time and so
i've always thought oh i'll use my
pillow even if it's not that great
and then i tried it and it is the best
these guys just know exactly what
they're doing
all come with a 60 day money back
guarantee you're not gonna need the
money back guarantee
go to mypillow.com click on the radio
listener square to check out the two for
one
low price on the giza dream sheets plus
free shipping there are also deep
discounts on all other my pillow
products too
enter promo code daily wire or call
800-651-1148
for these great radio specials and
podcast specials too not just radio but
also podcast specials
so i got in great trouble for this tweet
but it actually
it does show how the left misunderstands
politics and how the left misunderstands
their own political ideologies and the
right gets it a little bit wrong too
just to clear it up though just to clear
up the point because
the the tweet got ratioed you know many
many people were arguing about this
and i i sort of thought well if you're
speaking something
that is true from the perspective of
christianity you probably are going to
get ratioed you know i mean that's just
kind of the rule right people tend not
to love
the truth especially religious truth but
the church's teaching is very clear
about this
i will i will refer to the teaching of
the catholic church you know that i am
catholic
catholic church is uh is the oldest
church but
your mileage may vary if you are a
member of a different denomination but i
bet it won't
the catholic church has taught the
direct and intentional destruction of
innocent human life
from the moment of conception until
natural death is always wrong
and is not just one issue among many it
must always be opposed
joe biden seeks to not only defend but
to expand
abortion in this country and to make
taxpayers pay for it
and to permit abortion essentially
up until the moment of birth in certain
states certainly up until the moment of
birth
we cannot support that it is immoral for
faithful christians to support that
beyond it
as saint john paul ii taught in his
apostolic exhortation
christi fidelis above all the common
outcry which is justly made on behalf of
human rights
for example the right to health to home
to work to family to culture
you know all the rights that the left is
talking about all the time
is false and illusory if the right to
life the most basic and fundamental
right
and the condition for all other personal
rights is not defended
with maximum determination not
acceptable
to vote for joe biden and then beyond
the issue of abortion which is singular
it is not just one issue among many but
beyond that there is this worry about
socialism
joe biden is empowering socialists
job and kamala harris in particular
empowering socialists
christians cannot support socialism the
church has been very clear about this
from the beginning
many many many popes have written about
this pope leo
the 13th blessed pius ix saint pius the
10th
pope pius xi on and on and on uh saint
pope john the 20 or pope saint john
xxiii
rather who was considered not the most
conservative pope out there
but he while he was invoking pope pius x
said
a catholic cannot subscribe even to
moderate socialism
even if you want to say well it's just
kind of light little moderate socialism
aoc is not stalin i'm not so sure about
that but you maybe you could make that
argument doesn't matter
can't be even moderately socialist joe
biden has sued
nuns because they wouldn't pay for
abortion drugs he is promising to do
that again
it is not permissible for a christian to
vote for joe biden if you do that
if you vote for joe biden you are
imperiling your soul
for all of the reasons that i've just
mentioned and many others as well
religion defines politics cardinal
manning famously said
cornell manning a great religious
thinker and a great political thinker
too he said all human conflict
is ultimately theological when we're
arguing about taxes when we're arguing
about
immigration when we're arguing about the
death penalty we are having theological
arguments
there are there are premises about
spirit and religion and metaphysics
that are presenting themselves in our
political debates
we have a liberal country so we get
liberal policies other countries are not
so liberal
so they have other kinds of policies
poland for instance
is a catholic country there's that great
gif that everyone uses on twitter of
pope
pope saint john paul ii where he's kind
of like pointing out in the crowd and
doing the fist bump sign and he's
he it's because he was standing up to
communism and a million polls came out
in defiance of the communists and
chanted we want god we want god so it's
a catholic country and now they've got
catholic policies poland
just last thursday essentially outlawed
abortion in the country
great great news this was a
constitutional tribunal in poland
that ruled that abortions for fetal
abnormalities violate the country's
constitution
and they therefore imposed a near total
ban which are
there was already very intense abortion
laws in poland
and now there's a near total ban the way
that this is being presented in the
mainstream media
is that this is awful draconian terrible
that you're not allowed
to kill babies because they have
disabilities
meanwhile the left is always prattling
on and on about ableism and how we've
got to be and we can't say certain words
about people with disabilities we've got
to watch our language and be really nice
they don't give a damn about people with
disabilities they're trying to preserve
a fictitious constitutional right to
murdering
babies because they have disabilities
that can you imagine making those
opposite arguments at the same time
you would have to have the
compartmentalized mind
of a left winger and poland is now
reconciling this and saying no you're
not allowed to kill babies just because
they're disabled
sorry buddy now there were some protests
in the streets presumably because
a coronavirus is cured every time the
left wants to riot
but nevertheless nevertheless
they now have these correct good right
just
laws there new york times said in in
defiance of the dangers posed by
coronavirus
these women took to the streets imagine
if catholics took this to the streets to
protest abortion
uh something tells me the new york times
would not cover it in precisely
the same way not even anywhere close to
the same way
there are religious politics going on
now in france france is under attack
terrorist attacks took over france over
the weekend
okay don't forget by the way the french
republic
the the current kind of french regime
was founded by killing priests and
burning churches in the french
revolution one of the worst events in
the history of the world
that was the the essence of the french
revolution was the de-christianization
of france
how did that turn out christianity
remains persecuted in france today
there was a knife attack in nice france
in the notre dame basilica that's not
not notre dame like the church that was
burned down
for some unknown reason that we've never
gotten the full story on how that church
burned down
one of the most important churches in
western civilization but that's not
true notre dame that one we're talking
about a notre dame basilica
in nice uh two people were killed and a
fatally wounded third
woman was able to escape outside
she was a mother she her name is simone
barretto silva she was stabbed several
times she made it outside
and told the rescuers tell my children i
love them
before she died of her wounds
heartbreaking heartbreaking scenes in
france
many other attacks have been going on on
churches as well this is the third
terror attack on french soil
this month who's the attacker a 21 year
old newly arrived
muslim migrant from tunisia who is in
critical condition
after the police shot him and i suppose
it's good
that he's still alive for now to get
information about the attack
those are religious conflicts that we're
talking and this is it's most explicit
here right you have a muslim man going
in
and and killing people because they are
christian and we've seen many many such
attacks not just in france not just in
europe but also in the united states
this plays into another question which
is mass migration europe has essentially
opened borders
this this man who killed these people
was a very newly arrived migrant
from a country that is known for
extremism
does that play a role in our my
immigration debate we're not allowed to
say it does now but
certainly it does two more people were
taken into custody on saturday
who were apparently involved in the
murder who knows how
many people are involved total that that
means that right now they've got six
people in custody
they may have even more and do you know
how the new york times covered this
you can't make this up the new york
times is covering this by saying
is france fueling muslim terrorism by
trying to prevent it
you could you could predict it you could
always predict how the new york times is
going to respond to these things
which is whenever the west is attacked
they will blame the west they'll say
gosh it's the west's fault
that what what why did you wear such a
short skirt why did you go down that
alley at night
why why did you burn the roast that's
that's what
the left in the new york times want to
say a civilizational
self-hatred we will get to that very
very stupid
story but when we're talking about these
kinds of things you got to make sure
that you are safe online you've got to
make sure
because we're living in a very
politically hostile time right now
that's why i use expressvpn when i use
expressvpn these tech companies cannot
see
my ip address at all my identity is
masked and anonymized
by a secure vpn server you know there's
some stories that have come out
about people leaving their laptops
around and you know the things
that were not necessarily encrypted and
some material may have been hacked and
i'm just saying you don't want to put
yourself in that situation expressvpn
encrypts 100
of your data to protect you from hackers
and internet bad guys
does that sound complicated it's not
it's so simple even i can do it
expressvpn software takes one minute to
set up on your computer
and your phone you tap one button you're
protected i used to think oh who cares
no one's coming after my data
who who needs it don't worry about it
they'll go for somebody else
now i will not go online unless i have
a vpn it's so simple and for someone
like me i'm not
the most computer literate just click it
turn it on
your data are protected why give these
tech companies a free license to know
everything about you
and then turn around and sell off your
information it is time to take back your
privacy at expressvpn.com
michael mich ael by visiting my special
link you will get an extra three months
of expressvpn service for free
that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael expressvpn.com michael to
protect
your data today
marseille france begins the new york
times once again
terrorism strikes france and once again
terrorism is exposing the country's
dangerous
contradictions first there was the
murder of samuel pedia history teacher
who was decapitated
near paris on october 16th by a young
chechen man after mr pedi showed
students caricatures of the prophet
muhammad in a class about free
expression
then on thursday three churchgoers were
knifed and killed in the southern city
of nice
the prime suspect in that attack is a
tunisian man who later yelled allahu
akbar
goes on and on and on about these awful
kinds of
events but did
france invite it this is this is the
same argument that you heard from people
who said
the reason we we get attacked we got
attacked on 9 11
was because we're involved in the middle
east
or because we support israel or because
who knows because they don't like the
cut of our jib over there
when you are attacked
that isn't your fault when you were
attacked for
showing a picture of an historical
figure
that is not your fault when you were
attacked for practicing your
religion christianity the faith that
built your civilization it is not your
fault you did not egg on
the muslim attackers these are religious
conflicts but the left can't defend
that anymore because we can't or the
certainly the left but the
civilization generally i suppose cannot
defend that because we can't defend our
own civilization
because we don't really believe it
anymore we have become a
de-christianized
culture and civilization some people
still go to church i guess
but most people are leaving they are
leaving that religion and so people who
do believe in their religion
are going to come in and take it more
seriously we can't even defend free
expression we can't even defend
showing pictures of muhammad and and
this is not even just a left or right
problem neither side can defend it
because the left refuses to defend our
western tradition of free speech
and the right can't articulate any
standards
to by which free speech can be measured
what i mean by that is the the left has
completely abandoned our actual
tradition of free speech
but the right has been tricked into
accepting the the trap of
of the left and of political correctness
which seeks to overturn our old
standards we've always had standards of
speech
standards against obscenities standards
against fighting words standards against
sedition
standards against all sorts of things
that actually circumscribe free speech
but the right now can't can't defend
those standards so we've fallen into the
trap where we have no standards
whatsoever
no uh compass whatsoever
and so nobody can defend our traditional
civilization
and so it burns
the left summed this up a boston globe
op-ed columnist tweeted out
a picture of a trump parade
people in cars and trucks with trump
flags and american flags
and an isis parade people in
the back of cars in iraq or syria
holding up isis flags
and the boston globe columnist says see
the difference between these two groups
me neither
me neither because what the left is
seeing
is that the form is all that matters and
the substance doesn't matter
so if you believe in your religion
you're basically the same as al qaeda if
you're a really devout
quaker if you're like a really really
committed
lutheran you're the same as isis
now you might mention to them huh
actually you know i don't know if you
know this but
quakerism and radical islam are
different things and one of them
is fine and harmless basically and the
other one
is very dangerous to the whole world
if you said that you'd be called a bigot
you'd be called an islamophobe
you'd no different than than these
muslim terrorists
but it is different it is different the
devil is in the details here
there are differences now we are told if
you wave an american flag and if you
wave an isis flag it's the same thing
they they really believe that and what
the left doesn't understand
is that that belief that point of view
is essentially a religious point of view
it's just a different kind of religion
it's the religion of secular
liberalism which is the most jealous god
of all perhaps
because it doesn't even acknowledge that
there are other religions
in the world and and the democratic
party
the mainstream of the democratic party
is totally
captured by this now the people have
been saying well joe biden
he's kind of a moderate kamala harris
she doesn't believe in anything right
she's kind of a moderate
i don't think they believe in anything
deeply but they have
because they lick their index finger put
it up in the air and figure out which
way the wind blows
they have picked a side they've picked
the side of radicalism of socialism
of out-and-out communism it would seem
kamala harris
through the biden harris campaign put
out an ad over the weekend
describing the difference as she sees it
between equality
and equity she could not have gone
further to the left-wing extreme so
there's a big difference between
equality and equity
equality suggests oh everyone should get
the same amount
the problem with that not everybody's
starting out from the same place
so if we're all getting the same amount
but you started out back there and i
started out over here
we could get the same amount but you're
still going to be that far back behind
me
it's about giving people the resources
and the support they need
so that everyone can be on equal footing
and then compete
on equal footing equitable treatment
means we all end up at the same
[Music]
so first of all what kamala harris is
saying here just isn't
true she's drawing a distinction
essentially without a difference
equality and equity are the same thing
and they come
from the same basic root words
if there is a distinction though she
completely misunderstands the
distinction
because equality is the
state of having the same stuff you know
being being equal being
uh identical whereas equity
refers more specifically to fairness but
what she's describing isn't fair which
is describing as the opposite affair
which he's describing isn't justice it's
injustice she's saying
that you're going to end up in the same
place and then what she says is
completely
incomprehensible she says the problem
with
equality is we can all begin at the same
place or
rather we can all have the same shot but
we don't start at the same place
so we're not going to end up at the same
place so you need equity
this term that i'm redefining to make
sure that
everybody starts at exactly the same
place but then actually you've got to
end
up at the same place too and then we can
compete
right so she says that's we're going to
compete but
how how are you going to compete if you
are guaranteed to end up at the same
place
you can that's just a meaningless
addition because it
sounds like the kind of rhetoric that
you would hear in the american political
tradition
well we're going to compete and you know
every man is going to get what he can
get
but she doesn't really mean that when
you all end up in the same place
that is communism right that she is
describing and i'm not surprised she's
describing communism because she was
a senate co-sponsor of the green new
deal which was the most
radical piece of legislation ever
proposed in the history of the united
states
to redistribute wealth massively to
nationalize the entire energy industry
like something like 90 of american
energy to
tear people's houses to the ground and
rebuild them
as energy efficient greenhouses this is
a this is an
essentially communist plan i know the
distinction between
socialism and communism is a little
blurry the way it was once described to
me is that christians go to heaven and
socialists go to communism
it's just the utopian end state that of
course you could never get to
a vote for biden harris is a vote
for socialism or as she's describing it
here a vote for communism even
that is what you are getting
that is a very dangerous thing and by
the way
you are getting kamala harris you are
not getting
joe biden joe biden can barely
pronounce any words i will play you a
quote
of his in a second i want you to help me
to try to understand
maybe what he's trying to say but before
we get to that quote i want to thank
select quote because select quote
comparison shops
highly rated companies including
prudential banner life
and mutual of omaha and others to find
you the company with the best rates for
example
select quote can find a 35 year old man
a
half million dollar policy for less than
19
a month that is less than a dollar a day
a cup of coffee a day costs more than
that
significantly more than that select
quotes breakthrough technology allows
them to quickly match you
with the best insurance company to find
your best policy
plus quotes are free head on
over i i think it's really important
first of all
to get this kind of protection i know
friends and family who have not done
that and
sometimes very sadly it has not turned
out well get yourself peace of mind make
sure you take care of your family
and comparison shop you know make sure
you're getting the best rate possible
let select quotes save you time and
money get your free quote
at selectquote.com today that is
selectquote.com
for your free quote don't put it off
don't put it off
another day selectquote.com get full
details on the example policy at
selectquote.com
commercials your premium could vary
depending on your health issuing company
and other factors
not available in all states now let's
get to a much sadder quote joe biden's
quote i need you to tell me if you can
understand
what word or words
the possible next president is trying to
utter
i'll need an effective strategy to
mobilize true international effort to
pressure
i'll lead an effective strategy to
mobilize
trello
i listened to this quote i've probably
listened to it now 50 times
i think at least some of what he's
saying is true
true something international pressure
can we play that again can we go back to
that other true nala
i'll need an effective strategy to
mobilize true
international pressure so there are too
many syllables obviously in there but i
think what he's trying to get it is true
international pressure but i don't think
he's going to mobilize true
international pressure
i don't think that anybody is going to
pay him any heat at all
because his brain is putting i i know
it's sort of sad to say that
but the man is past his sell-by date
folks and so when you vote for him
i can't feel too sometimes i say oh i
feel bad for joe i don't feel bad for
joe i don't feel bad for guys who sue
nuns
because they won't pay for abortions i
don't feel bad for that i don't i don't
feel bad for guys who have lied through
their teeth for 50 years in government
and who have engaged in corrupt deals in
ukraine and china apparently
i don't feel bad for guys who may become
the president of the united states
i think we shouldn't feel bad for that
guy at all i think we should feel bad
for us if he gets elected
because that guy's not even gonna be the
president that guy is gonna go
he's gonna lie in bed and play tetris
all day
and either kamala harris are more likely
that bureaucracy is going to take over
maybe it was just a gaff maybe it's just
his childhood stutter that disappeared
for 60 years but then
somehow came back all of a sudden and we
have to pretend that it's a childhood
stutter when it's obviously not it's
obviously
decline well we got another one of these
examples
uh again this one i i don't think
there's any chance we're gonna figure it
out
but but joe biden is very focused on the
importance of
under barack and me it also
holds pluto i'll call polluters
accountable with the most ambitious
environmental justice agenda ever
okay so there you do get at least the
one word which is
polluters he is he is saying polluters
there but there are all these extra
syllables all around and then everything
slurs at the back end of this
joe biden is obviously exhausted these
incidents have gotten worse by the end
of the campaign than they were at the
beginning now
don't forget it for much of the campaign
joe biden has been hiding in his
basement
so you haven't gotten to see many of
these why did the biden campaign choose
to hide him in his basement they used
coronavirus as an excuse
but that obviously was simply an excuse
because they didn't want these moments
because they have seen him and they
interact with him
and they know that the man is obviously
in cognitive decline and he doesn't have
any stamina
i get it campaigns are really exhausting
i've been on a lot of campaigns
and i've been on campaign since i was 19
years old and even when i was 19 years
old i was exhausted doing them because
you're working 20 hours a day for 18
months at a time so i get it
but if you get tired from doing a modest
number of campaign events
like joe biden is doing how on earth are
you going to stand up to the pressures
of being president you can't do it
it is not possible and he won't
even if and i hope it doesn't happen but
even if he does get elected president
joe biden is not going to be a
particularly hands-on president
other people are going to do the job for
him
and unfortunately the the establishment
that that
he is empowering the groups that he is
empowering are socialists
radicals people who don't want equality
of opportunity
they want equality of outcome they will
go in they will take your money they
will redistribute it
they will institute a new american caste
system
that discriminates on the basis of race
and sex they are already doing that
and they are explicitly promising to do
it
that's what you're going to get with joe
biden
and some people are endorsing him
somehow lady gaga
i couldn't believe this was lady gaga i
saw a video going around the internet
of a woman wearing camo clothing next to
a big truck
cracking open a beer and i assumed it
was some kind of
satire or parody or but no it wasn't
it was just lady gaga endorsing joe
biden
hey this is lady gaga i'm voting for
america
which means i'm voting for joe biden
and if you live in minnesota
pennsylvania
georgia michigan florida or arizona
i encourage you to vote and if you have
a friend that lives there
tell them to vote i'm gonna be in one of
these states tomorrow
guess which one i'll be in hint i used
to live there
cheers to the 2020 election
where's the punch line i knew i assumed
the setup was going to be lady gaga's
wearing this kind of silly camo clothing
that no one
would expect her to wear she's next to a
big truck that no one expects her to
drive so i figured it was just going to
be a joke about
middle americans you know the typical
deplorable irredeemable bitter clinger
thing and she's going to say like ah
giha y'all
i'm voting for trump cause i'm dur i'm
an idiot huh you know like the kind of
thing that the life does all the time
but it wasn't that it wasn't that
because they know that if they do that
it'll turn off a lot of americans and it
will
have the opposite effect so i guess it
was just her
doing her best impression of what an
american looks like she said i'm voting
for america right so her best impression
of what an american looks like
which was not particularly persuasive
it's like that
meme of steve buscemi walking how do you
do fellow
kids how do you do fellow americans oh
yes that's uh oh
what you think i'm a left winger no no
i'm just an american
doing american things like drinking
beer beer yes i'm drinking a beer
standing next to a uh
a pickup truck yes this that's what this
one's a pickup truck right
the way you know it's completely
ridiculous by the way is think about all
the beer she just wasted
she took one little sip of beer and then
crushed it and
threw it on the ground you don't crush a
can and throw it on the ground until you
have finished the beer
i'm not even much of a beer drinker at
least i know that would never ever do
such a thing
i think she probably turned off a lot of
americans that way too
these these are totally different
visions of america it's funny that this
is a stupid clip it's obviously not
going to convince anybody to vote for
for biden but it does show you how the
left
misunderstands america doesn't get it
doesn't like america doesn't want to
have america
they can't do it they can't speak
fluently in the language of being an
american
they can't speak fluently in what what
we want
our country to be like because they want
something different
they want equality of outcome they want
a racial and sexual caste system
they want imported foreign ideologies
such as socialism
they want a materialist view of the
world where
electing them is going to save the
planet because they tell us that
armageddon is coming in 10 years
no one knows the day or the hour not
even the son but only the father and
apparently the left knows the day or the
hour too
it's a it's an entirely separate world
view
that they're offering us or you can vote
for america and i don't care how much
you don't like donald trump's tweets
that is this is about more than tweets
folks this is a bigger election
than that this election is incredibly
important
we are talking about a different
prescription you know very often
we hear this is the most important
election of our lifetime and then the
next election year this is the most
important election of our lifetime and
then the next election what do you hear
you hear the same thing
and we make fun of that we say oh it's
just politicians trying to get votes
sometimes that's true but sometimes it
really is the most important election of
our lifetime and there's no
contradiction by the way
if the next one is even more important
actually that would make sense wouldn't
it
if we're in so dire a position
politically in this country
that republicans fear rightly that we
could lose
the ability to win elections at a
national level if the democrats win if
the democrats win they're already
promising to end the filibuster
pack the supreme court and add two new
states which would end the republican
party as a national governing party you
couldn't win a presidential election
after that
because you'd be adding two democratic
states to the country end up ending the
constitutional order to say nothing of
packing the court which would end
any chance we have of getting a halfway
decent judicial ruling
so yeah obviously that election is the
most important election in your lifetime
if it means the extinction of your
political party very likely
but then what's going to happen next
election presumably that's going to be
the most important election
too might be even more important
depending on how they're jockeying for
power
there's no contradiction here you've
just got to
embrace the significance some elections
don't matter all that much
some elections really do make sure you
tune in tomorrow tuesday november 3rd at
3 pm eastern 12 p.m pacific
we will be streaming we will have
special guests live interviews and more
where we will be covering
the results with you in real time even
better join daily wire now get 25
off with code election so you can watch
all of our election coverage live on our
apple tv and roku apps
so watch the election with us at
dailywire.com
get 25 off your daily wire membership
with code election
e-l-e-c-t-i-o-n when you sign up
today head on over to dailywire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
so halloween happened over the weekend
and i know halloween i believe was
technically canceled this year because
uh you're not allowed to go outside or
see people and we're supposed to look at
everyone like a big bag of germs and by
the way joe biden says we're gonna have
masks through what 2022 or something
like that that's what fauci is saying
now too so
if you like that kind of a situation you
want to vote for more of it
vote for biden if you want to vote for
reopening the country vote for trump
some people still wore halloween
costumes alyssa milano went out there
and dressed as this is my this is the
favorite costume this year for the left
r b g the late justice ruth ginsburg
so first she tweets out uh happy
halloween rgb forever
rgb rgb is it rgb ruth ginsburg bader no
that's not her name
you love this woman so much but you
don't you don't know her name
okay then she deletes that tweet and
reposts says happy halloween
ruth bader ginsburg notorious rbg
but then i looked at how did she spell
ginsburg g-i-n-s-b-e-r-g
not how you spell ginsburg
so the left we are told we have to take
them seriously
on matters of jurisprudence on matters
of
political philosophy matters of the
constitution
even the justices that they love that
they idolize truly idolize
they can't spell their names dude maybe
the third time was the charm i don't
know if she tried a third go
they don't know anything about this i
mean you saw it especially last week
when they redefined court packing court
packing has
a specific definition so when you add
justices to the supreme court you
increase the number of
justices so that you are more likely to
get a judicial ruling favorable to you
they redefined that absolutely
definite possibility
with adding justices to replace justices
who had left
meaning following the constitution
reappointing justices
to the court they conflated those two
things very dishonestly
but the mainstream media totally went
with them all of a sudden the minute
you had one or two people mention this
in the air everybody new york times the
cable news channels came in and they
said well republicans have been court
backing too
they haven't they haven't they've just
been appointing judges as the
constitution tells them to do
completely different situation
republicans and conservatives have no
responsibility
to engage in these bad faith debates
with them they are not having a debate
they don't know anything about this and
they don't want to know anything about
this
they don't want to know anything about
the constitution they don't want to know
anything about the law
they don't want to know anything about
our founding they don't like our
founding
they don't like the country the premise
of progressivism now going back 100
years
is that the founding of the country was
wrong and mistaken
and now we need something else we need
to change it fundamentally
the premise of the 1619 project which is
now the hottest
framing of american history on the left
is that the country was rotten from the
very beginning
evil terrible and we need to undo the
founding of our country
and refound the country in a different
way along leftist lines to have a good
country
now we need to stop them from doing that
the way we stop them from doing that is
we suppress their anti-history
we boot them out of the institutions
that they've hollowed out and destroyed
and most notably the universities
and we beat them at the elections and we
don't allow them to
mobilize the bureaucracy to overturn the
results of the election like they tried
to do in 2016
after they had already spied on our
candidate in 2016.
that's how we went we don't we have no
obligation
to engage in a bad faith debate i like
good faith debates if a left-winger
wants to come up to me in a good faith
debate
i'm more than happy to do it i love that
stuff
but there is no reason to to take the
bait
you know we talk often about the free
marketplace of ideas and i suppose
there's something to be said for that
you want to you want to persuade people
but
the left has to be playing by the rules
of the marketplace and if they're not
if they are just coming in and
redefining terms willy-nilly
and doing anything they can to club you
over the head and
take away your political power you have
no need
to engage with that actually it'll just
be a waste of your time
you've got to win there are i think
three never trump republicans left in
the country
and what they are doing is wrong and
immoral and they should
they're doing it and you can listen to
their own arguments you know where
they're over at the bulwark which gets
three viewers every month
or places like bill crystal's websites
things like that
and what they what they are peddling is
sanctimony and self-righteousness
because they say trump is icky and i
don't like him and i want to be really
well regarded by liberals so i'm not
going to vote for him that makes me so
moral and pure it doesn't
it doesn't it's wrong it's wrong to do
that especially in an election like this
there is i mean i think you know where i
stand politically in this election i
haven't made any big secret of it
i have criticized trump on many
occasions
notice i often criticize him on on the
language around criminal justice reform
and that uh jailbreak bill that he
pushed a year or two ago
the first step act and there's there i'm
not
saying we need to agree with the guy on
everything
but he is the best president of my
lifetime there's no doubt about that
and regardless of mistakes that he's
made in office
i felt he should have reopened the
country much earlier with coronavirus he
didn't
doesn't matter he handled coronavirus
better than any democrat in this country
and he gets no credit for it andrew
cuomo his policies directly killed
thousands of elderly people
we can trace it and now he's trying to
cover it up by preventing investigations
into it
donald trump's policies did save people
i wish he had ended the lockdowns pushed
in the lockdowns earlier that would have
been better
but he still look it was a tough
situation once in a generation
and it's difficult to handle i don't
know there was no perfect way
to handle it there was no way to handle
it without a lot of damage around still
there's no choice
there's no choice in this election
obviously you got to vote for trump my
favorite
my favorite endorsement of trump came it
was just it went viral around the
internet
it's some older guy sitting in his car
explaining in really blunt terms the
stakes of the election
barry who you voting for donald j donald
trump
the gun why because he's the best
president since sliced bread
that is funny the man do what he say
he's gonna do i never see it yet in my
life
everything the man said he's gonna do it
do it then his sister his family trying
to put him down
she don't even know what a great man is
meant to have in her own damn family
he's sick he's
what about what about biden
that criminal in 47 years he didn't do
none for the black man
so you're telling people to vote for
trump right they have to
if they don't advert but trump is
finished brother god is in the midst
he's sealed and covered by the blood
they can't touch him
god sent him the right time believe me
i'm here 47 years
and this is the best the best is the
greatest thing since sliced bread
sliced bread you know he said it in a
funny way
so a lot of people say oh this guy is a
little bit crazy
show me the lie show me the lie in that
guy's
endorsement i think he's spot on it
actually goes on about a minute longer
he didn't have time to play the whole
thing i encourage you to go find it
though
because that guy makes a great point
trump does what he says he's going to do
that's what people have been so shocked
about with him
the key example is moving the embassy in
israel from from
tel aviv to jerusalem which most people
in america like don't really care about
that
all that much but it it i think it's
very important not even just for moving
the embassy
but because of what it says about
american power american resolve the way
we treat our allies the way we treat our
enemies
the way we treat our voters when we say
we're going to do one thing because both
parties in this country have been
promising to do that exact thing
for decades it had been the official
policy of the united states and everyone
just knew
they're not really going to do it so
when you'd hear a politician promise it
you'd say okay but what does that really
mean it really means he's not going to
do this
then trump gets in and trump i guess he
just he never learned that lesson so he
goes in and actually does it
people are shocked oh my gosh you can't
do that the thing you promised to do
the official u.s policy he's done it in
so many other ways
building the wall hasn't built the whole
wall but he's built a lot of the wall
actually
you'll you'll notice there were people
attacking them for lying about the wall
and then all of a sudden what do they
have like 750 miles built or something
it's pretty good it's actually
a lot of wall built with almost almost
half
so you know you need that second four
years so that you can finish building
that wall
uh re rejiggering trade deals nafta they
said you're never gonna renegotiate
nafta he did
you're never gonna get a trade deal with
china he did he did was actually pretty
favorable trade deal you're never
your trade fights are never gonna work
they did they did the guy said
what he was gonna do and he's doing it
joe biden
has accomplished very little in his
entire career and what he has
accomplished
is not so great generally a couple
couple things i like that joe's done but
but not many
not many so it's a question of which
direction you want the country to go and
it's not really about these individual
guys sometimes you would hear
you got to vote for the man i vote for
the man not for the party
if there's some really wicked awful
person then maybe i would abstain from
voting or vote for the other party
but that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about two guys who
represent two different
visions of america not two guys that
represent two different interest groups
and you know trump represents this the
white people
and the men and this and the but the
biden represents the
black people and the women and the
minorities and no it's it isn't that at
all
two different visions of america trump
represents a good vision biden
represents a bad vision that's it
and you see you see this the way that
the the endorsements are breaking down
huge breaking news in the rap community
lil wayne endorsed donald trump at the
end of last week
following on the heels of lil pump's
endorsement following on the heels of
fitty sense endorsement but then he
fiddy sent i guess unendorsed trump but
i think it was probably just to
do some creepy stuff with chelsea
handler again i suspect he's actually
going to vote for trump still
and kanye west of course endorsed trump
people talk about how is trump doing in
the black community i don't know how
trump's doing in the black community but
i do know he's making huge inroads in
the rap community
he's making it's insane rappers are
voting for republicans now
this is a reordering of politics and
that's what we're talking about for
tomorrow night
tomorrow night is going to be this huge
election and i don't have
predictions over what is going to happen
i've got my money on trump
i've i've bet a modest amount of money
on donald trump
i can't really come to grips with the
idea that biden is way up in the polls
and yet no one shows up to his rallies
at all 18 seriously like 18 people just
rallies
and you get 20 000 people at trump's
rallies like
it doesn't make sense to me that hillary
would lose in 2016
when there were many more reasons to
doubt trump and be afraid of a trump
presidency but now that he's done a good
job
now he's lost support and joe biden who
can't pronounce the meaning of words
who picked maybe the worst running mate
in presidential history
and whose campaign has openly embraced
socialism now in that campaign ad
that that guy is doing better than
hillary did that that guy is beating
trump
it's hard for me to believe that however
we do know that we're up against
a big issue in this country the
mainstream media big tech
big tech just took down the the new
jersey women for trump facebook page
huge private facebook group 23 000
members that's a private group so it's
much tighter knit more intimate they
took it down three days before the
election
so trump just tweeted that he goes at
facebook put them back now and then they
did they did go get your shine box too
they did put it back but there are a lot
of shenanigans going on and and
big tech and the entire liberal
establishment and probably the
bureaucracy as well
probably the bureaucracy people involved
in the election to varying degrees
are trying to prevent trump from winning
so we're up against a lot
tomorrow night could be over in five
minutes if for instance if trump loses
florida or something like that
or it could i could i could see joe
biden winning 40 states i wouldn't be
surprised
or i could see donald trump winning
every state plus greenland
and i wouldn't be surprised either i
just don't know
this election will show whether or not
the battle lines politically are so
ossified in this country
that we can never have a wide sweeping
election again
we used to have that republicans used to
win landslide elections
before notably before mass migration
that was a big factor in tipping it
but you know reagan 84 149 states nixon
re-election was a landslide
i could see a landslide again too in
either direction or we'll see if the
battle lines
have uh have ossified so much that we're
only fighting narrowly over these little
states
these little electoral votes and maybe
some guy wins the electoral vote another
guy wins the popular vote
if that happens that the temperature is
only going to go up it's anybody's ball
game but i will tell you
my money's on trump and the only way to
make sure
that we have the best chance of winning
that election is to go out
and vote of people who mailed in their
ballots early it would seem
the overwhelming number have voted for
biden there was another poll people who
were casting their ballots on election
day
overwhelming number for donald trump
which makes sense
because democrats are living and
cowering in the corner in fear and their
pods of the virus and the lockdowns
and republicans are living their lives
and so we're going to show up on
election day because we want our ballots
counted because we know
that some shenanigans take place
that is the stakes we will see tomorrow
how the next four years the next 40
years next maybe even longer than that
are going to be i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about
i hope you'll give it a listen
you